what's going on guys this is rob and and
i have this idea
you guys know how i get when i have
these ideas i feel like that's how the
most interesting videos open up even if
they just turn into nonsense over the
course of five minutes like
i have an idea
okay so here's the thing um i want to
talk about something because an image
has reached my
peripherals
uh apparently of you know little
figurines action figures whatever you
want to call them surrounding spiderman
no way home one of them is more lund now
i don't know how accurate this is i'm
going to err on the side of caution and
say it's 100 fake but what if it's not
what if mirlan isn't like spiderman no
way home right one how do you fit him in
there honestly i think it'd be a cameo
or a post credit scene at best and two
why would you because i think it'd be
fantastic if they did right if you have
more lun that means you have the
inheritors and if you have them you get
spider-verse you get a really really
cool story now it kind of makes sense to
a degree if you do this right because on
one side of the equation we've basically
got tom holland and we got toby garf not
garfield toby garfield we got toby
garfield and andrew mcguire we got tom
holland and we got toby mcguire
and we got andrew garfield they're the
live-action spider-man landscape right
now we don't know how extensive the
roles of toby maguire and andrew
garfield will be in spider-man no way
home they could be there for 15 minutes
they could be there for 100 minutes
we've mentioned that before they could
both be in this movie and die and like
that's how they kill them all that's how
they write them out right it's just like
tom holland's the only spider-man
anymore that's it there's no more toby
mcguire there's no more andrew garfield
none of that stuff they could be in
there everything gets fixed they go back
to their respective universes and they
continue in the multiverse now on the
other side of this equation you've got
into the spider verse right animated
miles morales and gwen stacy or
spiderman if you want to call her that
all that kind of stuff right that whole
thing over there spider ham and so on
and so forth i got to be honest with you
guys i have a hard time believing that
sony and even marvel studios
wouldn't bridge that gap
i have a hard time believing that
wouldn't be the case that there has to
be something there right they're gonna
have to do something with that it's just
too good of an opportunity right i mean
you do have the first animated film
which is called into the spider verse
but that was not based on the
spider-verse event it's just here's a
whole bunch of spider-man from across
the multiverse teaming up against the
threat and like that's it but wouldn't
it be cool if you had like andrew
garfield and toby maguire and tom
holland teaming up with like the whole
animated side and even some characters
that we haven't seen yet right i mean it
wouldn't be anything like cool world for
those of you guys who remember that
movie from back in the day
you guys remember cool world
some of you guys may be too young cool
world was uh
that movie was an experience back when
it first came out think of like
who framed roger rabbit on steroids that
was cool world it was pretty nuts
but nonetheless i think it'd be a cool
thing and there's great ways to make
that happen right i mean you could do it
in the blink of an eye you could do it
really really really easily you just
simply have some post-credits scene and
like spider-man 3 where like toby
mcguire gets back to his universe he's
immediately attacked by more line his
powers taken that's that right boom
we're on our way to the spider verse
right we're off to the races now for
those of you guys who don't know what
this means right because i know a lot of
you guys who read comics a lot of you
guys read spider-man you guys know
exactly what i'm talking about you may
or may not be excited about this those
of you guys who don't know what this
means more lon is a long-standing
character in marvel comics but he's one
of those characters where he's only
important because of the situation he as
a character is largely irrelevant
kind of
he was compelling for a while and then
nobody cared anymore so the idea behind
this at one point in time he had a guy
named j michael strzenski who was
writing the spider-man comics right j
michael strzenski is a guy who wrote the
story spider-man one more day i'm sure
you've heard of it for no other reason
than the fact that it's the story that
spider-man fans just can't get over and
they always they'll always stay pissed
off about that right it's a story that
like nullified the marriage between
peter parker mary jane watson peter made
a deal with the devil all that kind of
stuff what he ended up doing prior to
that point was building this whole great
big huge crusade about the story called
the other right basically introducing
this idea of spider totems and the way
this worked was that for years and years
and years peter parker was just a kid
who was bitten by a radioactive spider
and that's it and he got the
proportional strength of a spider and he
could crawl on walls and he had spider
scents and different things along those
lines no muss no fuss what strazinski
did is he introduced this idea by saying
that with peter parker being bitten by
this radioactive spider along with
anybody else right so like spider woman
any other character out there that was
bitten by a radioactive spider or in
some form or fashion was tied into the
mythos of spider-man radiation powers
all that kind of stuff they had kind of
been brought together by a sort of
mystical force and they were tied into
this and they represented spiders on
this kind of animal totem that totem
also includes the black panther t'challa
right like he is an avatar of the
panther god bass so he's part of that
whole animal totem thing that's that
exists out there the idea behind morlan
and the inheritors is they are
individuals that travel across the
multiverse killing individuals who are
part of the animal totem they absorb
their energies and it just makes them
more powerful than they were before they
kill that person and absorb their
energies they originate from earth one
also known as loom world basically their
kind of base of operations and you
actually did see moreland fight uh black
panther in reginald hudlin's run but one
of the cool things about this is that
the inheritors could very well exist out
there in the multiverse and they're
traveling across the multiverse killing
spider-man one of the things to know is
that when the spider-verse comic was
first introduced when it was first
released by mobile comics it wasn't as
though more lun was a new entry again
he'd been around for a little while but
even the expansion of the inheritors and
even when more lun was first introduced
he'd been around for a long long time
and he'd been killing spider-man and
spider-woman across the multiverse for a
long long time they've been doing it for
a while and so it's almost like with the
eternals right like you're just now
introduced to the celestials even though
you've kind of seen them a little bit
basically they've been around for
billions of years we're just now getting
around to the point that we see them why
well because who knows what they were
doing the universe is a big place man i
mean it's easy to get lost
it's easy to be all the way over there
doing stuff and we just never had a
reason to cross their paths until now
and so when you're talking about
something like the character of moreland
in in the marvel cinematic universe or
possibly just in the sony verse and more
lon is traveling across the multiverse
killing spider-man and spider-woman and
absorbing their powers along with the
other inheritors and they're gonna turn
out to be like this massive villain for
this huge coming together of all these
different spider-man from across the
entire spider-man mythos it works and i
think it's cool because the one thing we
don't have with regards to the
spider-man movies is we don't really
have a spider-centric event i mean we
had like avengers infinity war and
avengers end game and you could really
even say the whole first 10 years of the
marvel cinematic universe was largely
like an avengers centric event and even
a thanos and infinity stone centric
event right i mean literally all of
phase one is the infinity stones exist
phase two is now people are becoming
aware of them and phase three is thanos
got them that's literally it
that's the entirety of the first 10
years of the mcu summed up in five
seconds but the whole thing is that we
don't have like a tom holland andrew
garfield toby maguire miles morales
animated spider-gwen spider-ham we don't
have a spider-man centric event in the
films and i have to believe they're
building up to this man like i have to
believe that they are building up to
this whole thing i think it'd be cool i
think it'd be an amazing thing to see so
let me know if this is something that
interests you guys right again we're
wholly speculating here there is nothing
nothing out there to indicate this is
the case there's no leaks there's no one
out there like hey guys like more lon is
going to be in spider-man no way home
but you didn't hear it from me there's
nobody saying that right i mean it's
just it's an image that i saw it just
kind of got me thinking but i thought
it'd be cool right so let me know what
you guys think down in the comments
section if you guys would dig something
like this do you guys like it you guys
think it's stupid thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace